now on the third of april this year the
mp for somerset and froome david
warburton had the party whip removed
following allegations of sexual
harassment and drug use he faces a
parliamentary investigation
in the same month tiverton and honniton
mp neil parish now he resigned after
watching pornography in the house of
commons
then on may the 17th an unnamed 50 year
old male conservative mp was arrested on
suspicion of rape and sexual offences
allegedly committed between 2002 and
2009
and on may the 23rd the mp for wakefield
imran ahmed khan was jailed for 18
months for sexually assaulting a 15 year
old boy in 2008.
well the secretary of state for wales
simon hart joins me now good morning to
you mr hart
we know that chris pincher has resigned
his position as a deputy chief whip we
know that he has admitted that he drank
far too much uh did he grope
two men as as is being alleged
i don't know the detail i don't think
anybody else other than him and the
people in question probably know the
facts i think it would be dangerous for
me to speculate but you must have
expected that i would ask you this
morning have you tried to find out oh
yeah no absolutely but i think what for
me what's important is there isn't there
is a process this is this makes me very
sad it makes me sad for everybody
who's been involved in these things it's
it's uh
clearly something which has gone
terribly wrong there is a process i
think it's important the process is uh
is followed for the do we know that a
process is being instigated well we know
that there's a process there for anybody
who wishes to make a complaint
anonymously or in whichever way they do
they can do that and and will be treated
with the utmost seriousness uh and the
processes it's relatively new it's it's
really the thing is regularly
agreed and and um and i understand that
it's only alleged to have happened on
thursday night um it's also alleged that
it was witnessed by multiple
mps shouldn't an investigation just
automatically be triggered why does
somebody have to come forward and come
well i think this there are two things
here i think this was only triggered
last night the first any of us knew of
this was about eight o'clock last night
when he put forward his resignation i
think it is entirely right that the
chief whip and others take a view today
about what is the appropriate course of
action and of course if there are those
who are
victims of this or who wish to raise
complaint they can do so those two
things are slightly different
the chief whip looking into this and
deciding what to note is not dependent
on a complaint being made that can
happen anyway but what we need to i i
would like to think about what we need
to do is make sure that if anybody does
wish to make there is no we don't try
and pre-judge and we don't try and make
this uh uh more complicated than it
already is for them they should be
allowed to come forward anonymously if
they so wish and for the process to look
after them
and and hopefully allow them to come out
the other side it does sound a little
bit like you're hoping it just gets
swept under the car no i absolutely not
absolutely not i think you know you
listed a few examples this uh this is
not the first time i fear it possibly
won't be the last this happens in in
workplaces from time to time whatever we
made whatever we may think and and so i
i'm not trying i'm not trying to say
look just look the other way this is
something which is important absolutely
he's resigned his position as deputy
chief whip um this is a role which
involves being in charge of the
behaviour of other mps
should he keep the whip
that is a matter for chris heaton harris
his boss as i say this only really came
to light at eight o'clock last night at
seven o'clock this morning i think we
need to allow today to play out uh what
do you think i know it's a matter for
chris heaton harris but what do you
think
sorry sorry again whether he should keep
the whip well i i i hesitate to jump in
because if i express a view that's why
i've gone away in private business but
if i express it inviting you i know you
are i know i know you'd love to but it
is not my decision i i think and i know
what i'd like to see happen you can
probably tell what that is just from the
way i'm sort of trying to avoid
answering your question but it is
important i know it's the most boring
thing in the world when people like me
come on and won't give you a straight
answer that sounds to me like you think
he should
i just think let's let today play out
let the chief whip do his duty today uh
and then i think
i think we might be having a a very
different conversation as the day goes
on about this but it would be really i
think would be really counterproductive
particularly for the people who've been
affected uh by this we're really
counterproductive sometimes we come and
start sort of speculating about it no
but it sounds to me like you're saying
quite clearly that you don't yeah i mean
you may deduce that but it is a matter
for chris and i think it would be very
wrong with me to sort of do his job for
him let's talk about the judgment of the
prime minister because this is the
second time
that mr pinscher has resigned over
allegations of sexual impropriety and as
i was saying this is of course a role
that requires him to set the standards
really for how mps behave should the
prime minister have put him in that
position well i think the original case
if my memory serves surgery right was an
allegation which was made a long time
before chris pincher uh was even an mp i
don't know where it led in terms of the
uh
of the case at the time and i think you
know the pm and plenty of others by the
way not just him i've always taken a
view that uh if people have demonstrated
that they have
shown the necessary amount of contrition
and they and that
they that they can demonstrate that
they've actually uh
sort of recovered from the uh the
dreadful position that they would they
themselves went back like a second
chance can be given
i think it doesn't necessarily follow i
don't think that just because there was
uh uh a particular incident going back
uh in chris pinch's case quite a long
time that it necessarily precludes them
from ever having a job so contribution
those are different difficult judgments
to make contrition after sort of
sexually predatory behavior or
inappropriate behavior you think that's
sufficient to then go back into a
position where you're telling other mps
how to behave no but each of these
things is different each has a different
set of circumstances each have a
different set of consequences and it
doesn't always follow as i say that they
shouldn't be allowed to step back into
some form of public life ever again and
i think those are by the way those
aren't difficult judgments to make and
they don't always work out i absolutely
recognize that and this is this is one
such occasion where it doesn't you know
there's nothing i can say okay today
which is going to make this any better
for the people affected by it all right
i think we need to let today play out
okay well we'll see where we get to on
that but talking about conduct in public
office uh the metropolitan police as you
know been placed in special measures um
for not doing its job properly um should
uh which is being called for by the way
um by the way of a legal challenge
should they re-examine do you think the
prime minister's attendance at lockdown
parties
uh how are you connecting those two
things are you trying to suggest you're
trying to suggest
they've been pulled up for not doing
their job properly so some of the things
that being called for is that they
should do things again and do them
better so i'm saying should they
re-examine i think one of the things and
i've been in here being grilled by your
colleagues on plenty of occasions
around the work of the metropolitan
police and actually it was one of those
cases where i don't think anybody
including scrutineers such as
you know such a journalist ever thought
that the police were underplaying their
attention to that particularly in fact
uh
i i think everybody thought the police
did a pretty thorough job uh
that took place
inside the interface they did a fulsome
investigation in fact some people even
criticized them
you're not calling for them to
re-examine that no i think it was a case
of
as far as partygate was concerned they
looked at
in every possible way at that and nobody
criticized them at the time for having
underplayed it all right mr hart i know
you've been an unflinching supporter of
the prime minister what if the
privileges committee finds that he did
knowingly mislead parliament do you have
confidence in the committee to do a
proper investigation i think it's it's
so frustrating sometimes to be put in
this sort of hypothetical position where
there's an enquiry or an investigation
coming up and we're being asked to
second guess uh one of the potential
scenarios and and expressive the whole
point of having these inquiries is that
people can take a long cold
evidence-based look at all of the
information so the worst thing that can
happen is for anything is an mp from any
party for that matter suddenly popping
up
on the telly and second guessing where
that might lead some of your colleagues
have described the process as a kangaroo
court i'm just wondering what you think
i don't i don't agree with that by the
way um i think these commit i've been on
loads of these committees i was on the
committee for standards of public life
for quite a few years and we didn't uh
we took our work seriously and i every
select committee i know
takes its work incredibly seriously uh
and and objectively and i'm sure this
committee is no different all right well
we'll find out won't we um rumors
swirling of potentially a snap election
being called the prime minister hasn't
uh denied it what do you think oh
another another week another election
rumor it seems um this literally has
been going on pretty well since the last
election and uh there is no i'm inviting
you to deny it i i am tonight i mean i
i'm good
the things we talk about um never
involve in cabinet for example never
involve uh right where you know when
when are we gonna have the next election
because we and and it sounds
you've probably heard this a million
times but it sounds like the sort of
answer you'd expect which is we are
concentrating on some serious stuff
around cost of living
exactly and and but we are and i think
sometimes we come out of cabinet people
saying you know did you discuss this did
you the answer is no we discussed the
things which okay so you are denying you
are denying that there is talk of a snap
election as far as you know people
listen i read the same rumors as you do
but no i mean internally but
i've absolutely given you a cast iron
sort of solid guarantee that i've not
had a single conversation with a
colleague whether it's in the party or
the government about an early election
right okay um
my uh colleague is running a story today
um where apparently the pressure that's
being put on civil servants to come back
to work not to work from home uh there's
no room for them what do you have to say
about that apparently there's not enough
desk space if they all came back
uh not a story that i've uh heard to be
honest with you and i think the civil
ser i think sometimes uh that this comes
across as a as a as a sort of battle
between government and the civil service
um in my in in the world's office which
is a relatively small uh government
department uh we have a really i'd like
to think we have a really good
relationship it's very sort of
it's very mutual uh we we try to do
everything we do respectfully and uh the
working from home culture i think has
been moving slowly back to a work from
an office culture since the pandemic
bearing in mind there's still plenty of
code we're telling you still plenty of
coconut still plenty of covert about by
the way so we need to you know what are
you telling your staff mr hart are you
telling them you want them back in the
office absolutely where possible and
where there are no safety risks all of
the usual caveats attached and you've
got space for them but we're not having
well actually we have but my my
department is probably a bad example
because it's relatively small but
actually we're not
we're not finding we have to order
people to do anything actually
in my case in our case civil servants
are a fantastic work companies they if
and if they possibly can come back uh
they are i'm not having to wheel the
whip or anything like that okay so you'd
be happy to see them uh should they
choose to go uh big headline
announcement about the increase in
defense spending
yesterday at the same time uh government
plans to cut ten thousand army troops
should the government should mps be
getting a vote on whether or not to go
through with what's pretty much mps
ultimately have a vote on all of these
things whether it's part of a budget
whether it's part of a spending review
whether it's part all of these things
are subject to uh voting and then
there's an opportunity for select
committees to explore all of these
things the opposition can put forward
motions which are votable so uh there
are plenty of ways
parliament can express its view on this
and if the majority of mps uh are
opposed to the cutting of army troops
then that just won't go ahead well it
it's always looked at normally in the
context of the overall budget and as
also was mentioned yesterday that's
going to move to about two and a half
percent of gdp that's a problem by
twenty thirty by twenty thirty
absolutely by uh that's that's a pretty
significant figure if you look at
international uh comparisons and i think
just looking at the army from the basis
of the number of personnel given we're
in a very different sort of
technological uh space than we were
maybe 10 or 20 years ago as far as
defense is concerned it's possibly it's
possibly
limiting our horizon i think we need to
look at the whole piece of military
spending and exactly what that looks
like and and i think it's you know for
me
with a semi-military background um i
think the fact that we are remaining
absolutely resolutely resolutely
committed to 2.5
is great i think you know the
circumstance of ukraine may not be a
particularly uh pleasant backdrop for
all of this but i'm delighted to see
that we are not flinching uh and and you
know we're confronting a cost of living
uh challenge which not flinching by
2030. well no but you can't do these
things you can't just click your fingers
and suddenly get to a dead these things
take a long time to build up defense
procurement recruitment and all that
stuff can't there isn't a magic switch
you can just press and it all happens
overnight these things do take time uh
but i think the fact that we are making
it very clear what our intentions are it
for me as somebody with you know deeply
embedded in uh in a sort of military
background i i i look at that as a good
news story in a difficult period of our
history
all right uh thank you very much for
your time this morning simon hart thank
you